bombardier relève ses objectifs pour les
deux prochaines années bombardiers
prendre l'avance sur son plan
stratégique et prévoit maintenant
s'attaquer au marché de la défense dont
elle espère générer un revenu d'un
milliard de dollars d'ici 2030 avec nous
ce soir pour en parler Eric Martel le
PDG de Bombardier bonsoir Monsieur
Martel bonsoir Monsieur Fillon de vous
recevoir ce soir parce qu'on apprenait
cet après-midi que le gouvernement
canadien explore la possibilité
d'acheter 16 avions Boeing Poséidon p8a
pour remplacer les CP 140 Aurora c'est
un contrat que vous aimeriez avoir chez
Bombardier absolument écoutez on a créé
l'an dernier une division de défense
chez Bombardier parce que on a des
plateformes et des produits qui sont
reconnus partout dans le monde sont
extrêmement capables et performantes
alors on offre des choses aujourd'hui
que probablement les avions plus
traditionnels comme celle qui est que
vous mentionnez ici sont incapables de
faire c'est des l'altitude des vols les
distances qu'on peut parcourir donc
plusieurs capacités qu'on est capable
d'ajouter et on a beaucoup de succès
depuis un an dans la division on fait
des avions présentement pour le
gouvernement américain on fait des
avions on a un contrat c'est public pour
l'armée allemande et on aimerait bien
dans notre propre pays et être capable
d'avoir la chance de proposer faire une
proposition gouvernement parce que il y
avait des discussions et initialement
qui allaient peut-être octroyer le
contrat directement à Boeing mais je
dois vous avouer qu'on a eu des
discussions dernièrement on n'a pas des
réponses claires encore mais ce que nous
souhaitons bon mardi c'est qu'il y a une
appel d'offres j'aimerais avoir la
chance de proposer notre produit fait au
Canada pour une solution canadienne et
donc on vous a pas dit que vous alliez
pouvoir faire on attend toujours une
réponse et là on comprend la déclaration
du gouvernement canadien qu'on
s'intéresse beaucoup aux appareils
Boeing seulement c'est un con ça va être
notre compétiteur principal mais on a
fait un avion qui est beaucoup plus vert
qui va consommer beaucoup moins
d'essence que des meilleures
performances en termes d'altitude en
termes de distance et tout alors on va
et donc c'est pas perdu pour vous
occupé on attend confirmation du
gouvernement qui vont nous permettre de
soumissionner c'était énorme ce contre
là si je me trompe pas c'est quoi ce qui
est surtout important pour nous c'est
que ça peut devenir l'avion
technologiquement qui remplacerait
beaucoup d'autres entre autres le P8 là
qui est un des avions à faire par Boeing
alors on souhaiterait que notre pays ne
choisisse pour qu'ensuite de son on
puisse l'offrir et remplacer il y a une
flotte de 180 P8 aujourd'hui qui vole un
peu partout sur la planète et le Canada
les derniers achetés d'ailleurs Boing
mène pression sur le gouvernement
canadien en disant on arrête de le
produire nous on arrive avec un produit
haut de gamme avec des nouvelles
technologies qu'on dit on va être ceux
qui vont remplacer éventuellement cet
avion là pourquoi que le Canada serait
pas pour cette fois là devant et
permettre quoi cet appareil là
exactement cet appareil là c'est un
appareil de surveillance donc alors ce
qui permet de faire c'est un avion qui
peut voler très haut la terre est en
ronde plus on est au plus on est capable
d'avoir des missiles qui pourraient être
lancé exemple par une un ennemi de façon
proactive et puis pouvoir réagir plus
rapidement c'est un exemple de
d'application ou les sous-marins repéré
des sous-marins et puis la surveillance
des côtes
la partie militaire par rapport à ce que
vous faites parce que là vous êtes
concentré dans les dernières années sur
les avions d'affaires
militaire dans l'avenir de bonbons parce
que dans le fond ce qu'on ferait c'est
qu'on utilise des plateformes nos
plateformes existantes le challenger et
le Global ensuite on prend ces
plateformes là on travaille souvent en
partenariat avec des équipements entiers
qui vont fournir des équipements qu'on
va installer des équipements de
communication des équipements par
exemple de surveillance des radars et là
ça souvent ça modifie la forme
extérieure de la vision alors on est
bien placé pour faire ça parce qu'il
faut recalculer ces rebalancer
aéronautiquement l'avion alors nous on
est capable de faire ça puis on le fait
d'ailleurs dans le monde présentement
pour d'autres gouvernements c'est un
secteur quand même qui est en
fluctuation par rapport aux avions
d'affaires qui va rejoindre une
clientèle par exemple assez riche
le marché militaire pour vous serait
l'air de quoi si vous vous lancez ce
marché représente à peu près 300
millions de dollars iOS de vente par
année pour nous on pense que dans la
deuxième moitié de la décennie on
pourrait tripler l'amener à un milliard
parce qu'on a des plateformes
extrêmement performantes sur laquelle on
peut mettre des équipements vous savez
aujourd'hui les équipements qu'on met
sur de plus en plus miniatures alors on
a plus besoin des gros appareils alors
ça permet d'avoir des avions qui vont
consommer qui vont être beaucoup moins
cher à opérer et qui vont évidemment
plus vert les choses vont bien pour
Bombardier très bien
[Rires]
c'est que ça a tellement mal été pour
Bombardier que là qu'est-ce qui va
qu'est-ce qui fait que Bombardier qu'on
est dans une résurrection complète de
Bombardier en ce moment j'adore le mot
résurrection mais on a eu des années
difficiles je pense qu'il faut être il
faut être transparent là-dessus vous
savez on a fait une restructuration
majeure en 2020 début 2021 et à ce
moment-là je pense qu'on est sorti on a
dit au marché écouter on a un nouveau
bombardier on est sur les avions
d'affaires d'ailleurs c'est la division
de défense on utilise nos avions
d'affaires donc c'est pas des nouveaux
c'est les avions qu'on a déjà qu'on va
partout sur la planète vous savez qu'on
a 5000 avions qui volent un peu partout
dans le monde et aujourd'hui on les
produits ici au Canada ses avions là et
bon mardi aujourd'hui et dans une
position extraordinaire on a eu
d'ailleurs une accélération aujourd'hui
on a presque 2 ans de carnet de
commandes devant nous sa nouvelle dans
une solution stable on a remboursé 45%
de notre dette depuis le début et ce 2
ans de carnet de commandes-là nous donne
de la prévisibilité et on a vraiment
stabiliser l'organisation augmenter vos
prévisions de revenus les prévisions de
liquidité l'action à grimper de 250%
quand même effectivement est-ce que la
taxe la taxe de luxe que le gouvernement
Trudeau a adopté ça vous devez
l’appliquer ou à vos clients bah écoutez
à date on l'a pas appliqué parce que ça
leur vraiment arrêter les ventes au
Canada depuis je joue ça là je suis très
pratique et la réalité c'est que la taxe
est en application depuis septembre
dernier
nous on doit collecter les taxes pour le
gouvernement mais on a livré aucun
appareil au Canada on a collecté aucune
taxe l'an dernier et cette année on
prévoit un collecter aucune
les clients pour annuler mais ils n'ont
pas acheté puis on avait à peu près 19
clients avec qui on parlait on parle de
ce privé de revenus d'environ de 835
millions de dollars iOS présentant
bombardier seulement alors c'est une
situation perdante perdante dans le sens
que finalement le gouvernement qui
souhaitait collecter des taxes dans le
collecte pas en tout cas sur la
visibilité qu'on a ni même cette année
et nous ça nous prive de fabriquer des
avions de plus qu'on pourrait vendre au
Canada le Canada toujours représenté 5 à
6% quand même de nos livraisons et donc
vous demandez l'abolition de cette taxe
là je comprends qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement de mis en place pas juste
pour les avions ce que nous on a demandé
c'est au moins de réduire aussi la
portion que les gens doivent faire la
démonstration sur une base continue du
pourcentage qu'il utilise pour eux-mêmes
ou pour leur
business dans le fond et aujourd'hui
c'est à 90% d'utilisation pour le
business alors peut-être que si on
baisserait ça ça pourrait aider aussi
c'est une demande qu'on a fait il y a
quelques mois ok Monsieur Martin merci
merci de votre présence avec nous ce
soir merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]